hello and welcome to the active inference lab today it is october 25th
2021 and we are here in active guest stream number 12.1 with martin boots so
this is going to be an awesome presentation and discussion if you're watching live please feel free to add
any questions into the live chat and we'll be compiling those and otherwise we're just gonna have a
presentation and then discussion interval so martin thanks so much for joining our lab to give this
presentation and we're really looking forward to what you have to share yeah a big pleasure to be here tonight
or this morning i guess for you guys in california
so let's see if i get the screen sharing here right again we
practiced it before this should be this one here looks great
and now i just need to have at least one video on the side here for me
so yeah big pleasure um to present our labs work on which i call event predictive
active inference and particularly also modeling the development of conceptual compositional cognition
from sensory motor experiences you might have already um kind of noticed uh the
picture here this artistic picture on the top right and i think it shows
nicely and intuitively how our brain continuously seems to attempt
to infer the hidden causes behind our sensory perceptions and thus
this kind of terrace is kind of bent for us a little bit because the top part of
course um just can be interpreted in two ways and is obviously
not quite rightly positioned or or yeah it cannot be like
this in reality we give you a couple of other examples what i mean by this
active inference which is known to or explained often by carl frist and others to extend essentially
develop latent hidden states to explain away the sensory
perceptions by inferring the hidden causes behind them so here you see a color illustration
which is called color illusion sometimes where you probably won't believe it i
have to measure it each time again to make sure that i'm really right but essentially in this yellow tinted
figure essentially these blue colored squares here they are essentially grayscale now they are if
you test them by um in the graphics program you will see that this is a grayscale
position so all blue points here in fact grayscale and here on this side with a blue tinted background you essentially
have the same situation but it's the yellow pieces that are actually grayscale this is illustrated
here on the right a little bit and this just shows essentially that our brain
is interpreting its sensory perceptions in the light
more and logically fitting here um of the circumstances yeah and in this
case yellow light makes a true blue square appear gray when we look at it so
we perceive it gray the sensory stimulation is gray but the true
cause behind it must be a blue square so i our brain essentially correctly and
actively infers that this square is most likely blue because under this yellow light conditions it appears gray and we're not
even aware of that so this is a lovely an example of a very low level
inference process in our brain that takes into account the situation and essentially puts the perceptual
sensory information in this event this light event this lightning condition essentially
another um nice example of this is these shadows that i found here online from
from some artistic exhibition and you have here two shadows and as long as you look at the shadows
and you perceive the shadows you kind of not only perceive the shadows but you perceive a person and the illustration
of a person and to a certain extent you have the feeling that some person must be standing here somewhere such that i
will perceive these uh these shadows but lo and behold um this situation is totally different
these are actually cool artistic sculptures that produce the shadows and
um again you see that yeah you have perceived a shadow and
interpreted not only the shadow but created a whole scene a whole event like with a light source and the person in
the middle and then the shadow that produces this in order to make sense of the shadow itself yeah so again you
infer the hidden causes behind the shadow in this case not quite correctly
because it's a cool illustrative cool artistic
sculpture here that with a installation with a light source perfectly positioned such that
the sculpture creates a particular human-like shadow figure so the first proposition that i uh
take out of this essentially that our brain seems to be this generative predictive
model and uses active inference essentially with this generative predictive model
generating inferring internal activities that is internal active and codings that try to
explain away the current sensory perceptions and thus make sense of it in the sense that we
explain them away by ideally inferring the true hidden causes
behind the perceptions that we actually perceive this generative predictive model as
explains away perceptions it maintains distributed predictive activities
um which form this kind of attractors which often then are formalized particularly
by carl fristen and his followers so to say and in various ways um formalizing this and
essentially suggesting that the brain develops this local free energy minima
this local attractor like minima that is the consistent explanation of a
particular perception that we are currently have under consideration so um this would be for example in the
shadow situation right we perceive the shadow but we know uh intuitively that there's a light
source and something in between that produces a shadow and thus in the in the shadow of a person we essentially
immediately have the feeling that some person must be standing there the free energy formalism essentially
pushes towards the generation of these generative predictive models
and pushes towards the continuous active inference processes that are unfolding within these
developing generative predictive models and one can nicely distinguish three kind of aspects of this general
inference process formalism and that is on the one hand side on the first inside knowing what is going on so
that's essentially the fast adaptation of internal model activities towards this local free energy minima
to explain to ourselves what's going on so if we looked all together at the shadow and we perceived the shadow then
um you perceived not only the shadow but you had the feeling that you inferred
the causes that is that there is a person in the light source that creates the shadow yeah
then the second part is learning more about the world we can revise our generative predictive models for example
you have now revised your predictive models learning about that there are some cool people that make sculptures
that produce human-like shadows and there's no human actually but just a sculpture and so you have learned
something new about the world essentially and we do the first two aspects of inference aspects essentially
of course only to really survive in our world to live to interact with our world in better manners so to really pursue
our goals and our knowledge driven behavior our
epistemic behavior with them by the means of these developing generative predictive models
let me explain it a little bit further so so it's clear how i mean this
so essentially also implied by the generative
by the free energy formalism and the active inference formalism one can say that our brain is continuously
on the one hand side in the present for sure right i mean we are ready while we for example write a
letter here we are ready to produce the next word and write it out
on paper for example we consider the recent past while doing this to be
really in the present and fully embodied and grounded in the here and now
the present is also continuously updated by our
sensory feedback while we interact with environments for example we might update
our belief how sturdy the pencil is or how hard it is and things like this
and we learn um about our world while we interact with it such
as improving our writing skills and so forth but most importantly we use this
representation of the presence and the belief where we are in essentially to
predict the future what is going to happen if we like his future considerations and then
essentially to pursue particular future desired situations such as finalizing
writing this letter writing this word producing a letter for another person
and having overall purposes also other purposes of course for the current day and so forth and these considerations
depending on our focus the difference between the desired future considerations and the current expected
future considerations make us improve our behavior and act in a core directed
manner with the environment one can illustrate this in a different way by
essentially saying um well the active inference pro framework essentially suggests that we
are continuously in a predictive state of mind ready to produce to process the
next sensory information doing information integration there producing local posteriors
integrating this local posteris perception with our overall beliefs in our model so perceiving the shadow
inferring that there's probably a person in light source that produces a shadow integrating an overall
consistent in attempting to create an overall consistent a posteriori predictive state of mind and we use this
state of mind essentially to roll out future considerations including
habitual behavior with our environment test if we like this if we want to go
there or if we want to pursue particular other um other other states in the future
choose the best one we can do execute it and then close the loop by using the reference copy to do the temporal
prediction in the here and now this
epistemic goal directed behavior can essentially be formalized nicely in this
reasonably short equations still to um to generate um goal directive
epistemic behavior this comes from fristen and pesolos and ielts work in
2015 um which essentially um i think it's a very nicely formalized
intuitive equation here actually so let's see we pursuing the minimization of free energy under a particular policy
pi at a certain state t and pursuing this free energy consists of two components the first component is
essentially the pursuer the goal directed component in this equation is essentially
trying to minimize the difference between the observations that i expect to perceive when i pursue a particular
policy pie also a particular behavior pi and compared to the observations that i
would like to perceive under my internal model so this is essentially the expected
divergence from desired future states and i pursu i try to then of course
infer a policy price or behavior pi that minimizes the divergence from the
expected future states to the desired future states the other component in this equation is
the epistemic part it's essentially the minimization the attempt to minimize expected future
uncertainty so it's the expectation of over my future horizon tau that's my
timeline into the future as you see here and it's essentially the ex the
expectation of future uncertainty which i try to minimize it as well so under my
uh consideration of my policy pi i expect future internal states m tao and this end house under the
policy uh lead to the expectation of future observations and the uncertainty of this observations or the observation
densities essentially um so the entropy over that the more uncertain that
the more diffuse my expectation the more uncertain my expectation the less i like
these future considerations and out of these two components in the equation one can essentially um derive agents that
act in goal-directed and epistemic manners we have done
implemented such agents mainly partially
as rather still rather crude approximations simply with recurrent neural network structures here for
example this rocket ball agent that was uh is controlled by a neural network
on the fly essentially by first training the network to learn the sensory motor
model of this agent so this agent undergoes gravity and has inertia in the
simulation in 2d and has these two thrusts that go diagonally
diagonally downwards so it can counteract gravity and steer as you see
essentially and the red line that you see here is essentially the imagination of the
neural network where it expects to fly to over the next couple of steps so essentially the system rolls out as i
illustrated before essentially into the future it's sensory motor dynamics expected sensory motor dynamics under
expected motor control commands that it imagines executing
and it then compares this uh the resulting state with the desired state can take the kel divergence or simply
the delta if it's deterministic and pro use that delta to project it
back onto the motor commands so that's uh the system essentially acts in its own best interest to uh
pursue these goals the goals are given from the outside in this case so this is still a rather simple system
in the sense that it's not probabilistic really or tries to minimize uncertainty here but just pursues goal-directed
behavior we have also done this with various other systems for example multi-joint
arm that additionally has the constraint to avoid collisions which are signaled by
this hair sensors as you see here and you can also get quite some cool behavior very similar principle and so
to conclude the first part right now i hope you have understood the active inference component
and inference is about essentially also suggesting implicitly that our mind
is not only about knowing what is going on it also continuously learns about the world retrospectively so it's partially
also in the past in some sense in its activity state and in the future considering um and inferring goal
epistemic behavior however this
is certainly good and we can generate close-loop control systems in this manner which are closely related
to model predictive control for that matter but in order to really
become event predictive or more abstract in our scene right right now essentially
you have seen a system that only is just writing something or is controlling a flying trajectory right it's not really
able to decide to write a whole letter right in the sense right abstractly speaking so
it's not able to abstract away from the actual current behavior
so the question is how where do these event predictive structures that i was talking about come
in and that leads me to my second proposition it's essentially that uh that it appears to be
that due to evolutionary shaped inductive processing biases our brain develops event predictive
compositional structures these structures tend to model the hidden causes behind sensory perceptions i have
already intuitively seen it i want to illustrate this further with an actual model behavior but before i do so let me
characterize where this event where this proposition essentially comes from right where where does this believe that event
predictive structures are the right way to go are the right way to abstract forward and it comes from from the
psychological literature mainly and i start with a quotation here from
jeff sex and barbara twesky from 2001 which essentially reads okay event
events have been characterized as a segment of time at a given location that is conceived by an observer to have a
beginning and an end and their behavioral psychological
work essentially suggested that when you have people segment movies or other little scenes or
cartoons even and things like this they do this very systematically so they have a really clear perception when an event
starts and when it ends and out of this it appears that we process
our environment in terms of we perceive our environment in terms of these events
but important is that the event is it's not really in the environment per se
right there's no label this is an event yeah but our brain constructs these events and that's what uh what their
boyfriend lovely put into a recent special issue contribution so she says
or baldwin and kosi should i say events the experiences we think we are having
and recall having had they are constructed they are not what actually occurs because what occurs in the end is
ongoing dynamic multination multi-dimensional sensory flow which is somewhat transformed via psychological
processes into structure describable memorable humidity of experience yeah so essentially right
there's no label of events but our brain creates this abstractions and this compact encodings
of the events that we perceive of that exist in our environment but
we construct them essentially they are not really existing on their own
and over last years a lot of research has focused on this event predictive
cognition and this research essentially investigates how events and conceptualizations thereof are learned
structured and processed dynamically and this research line essentially suggests that event predictive encodings and
processes optimally mediate between sensory motor processes and language uh maybe i should
have put inference processes here so this is a quote from our recent special issue so in summary this event
predictive cognition essentially comes from um psychological richer um trasky's work
with jeff sex and jeff sex continuation until today actually there's much more recent work from him about this it's
rooted partially even more deeply in behavioral psychology if you look at the common coding theory of uh within prince
and answered our behavior control theory of jachim hoffman and bernard thomas
work on the theory of event coding if you want to learn more about this i'll
allow me to point you to our recent special issue on this topic in the topics in cognitive science
journal with quite a variety of contributions spanning developmental neural
and behavioral psychology also linguistics
contributions and cognitive modeling and computational ai contributions
so what are these event structures now really about um it's essentially when we think about
particular event predictive structures right one can quickly get to the conclusion while
events must be somewhat disdistributed networks that essentially predict the types of entities that are
involved in event like a glass and a hand and an agent that
reaches for the glass to drink drink out of it the relative spatial relations between the hand and object for example
and the interaction dynamics such as the hand really moving to that object these are event structures
and then we have somehow this feeling of event boundaries and event transitions we know when a particular event can
commence and when it can end when it can begin and end and so for example when i grasp this cup
here i just can basically grasp it and once i have grasped it i can transport it and then i can put it
back down and i'm free again so to say combined with events and event
boundaries i create i can create mentally event schemas which have previously in prison also called scripts
and similar things and i think these scripts and develop naturally out of this event predictive coding principle
and with the event predictive coding principle we essentially have now a much more clear idea i think of what the
scripts and schema ties that have often been characterized before actually are and of course once we have schemata we
can embed them again in other events forming hierarchies out of that so to get back to this illustration of
writing a letter we can now say essentially well we our mind is not really
in a continuous past consideration but it con considers past events essentially
or the unfolding of past events and notice that this do not need to be partitioned as crisp as it's illustrated
here and we have certainly events unfolding in parallel for example if you think about the letter writing here
right you're writing for example the second word here say scholar or so but
you also have the full writing this letter event in your head this event of
having sit down on the table and being ready to write this letter so there are multiple event aspects of course that consider
particular sub-components of the actual true environment out there
and so again we know what's going on we can retrospectively improve our individual writing skills
for writing particular words writing in general but also our skills of writing a whole letter and improving this for
example and then we can again pursue the events of finalizing this letter posting
it later on and so forth so we have a full sequence in mind that actually
then includes the or concludes the full letter writing episode
that is not only doing the letter but also putting a stamp on the envelope putting the letter in the envelope
putting it to the post office and so forth so all this is included um
for the fun of it i included this lovely video project here um so here we see an
event of a of a billiard ball a pool table uh starting situation and somebody is
shooting the white boy and and so we have a nice hit and we look oh some balls hit the
hole no they don't actually lo and behold they come back together to the
starting position so i hope the video was a nice illustration of you
definitely having expected something totally different although not something very concrete but at least the final
state of the event that the balls will be distributed around the table in some form or the other certainly they will
not ever come back to the starting uh position like this and that's why hopefully some of you
were at least a little smiling to themselves yeah that it's a kind of a cool illustration here that my brain has
his events in mind and it essentially steps jumps ahead right when the
starting of an event unfolds it kind of knows what the final situation is most likely
going to be even if it's not fully concrete but it still has some in the ball situation the
pool ball situation a distributional um sense to it so it's also really
interesting and we have lo and behold actually formalize this event predictive active inference
now in an eventbritic effective inference model where the model
reaching behavior and visual eye fixation behavior in infants actually
together with colleagues from from potsam university from development development psychology side so now we
essentially have the same same equation again as before but it's
only condition now on events here as you see so the whole equation is
conditioned on in which events we believe to be currently in so the latent hidden state this model we had before is
now an event model and um and so and we we put the m basically as
the internal motivation so the desired observations given motivations are compared with the expected observations
pursuing a particular policy and under condition that we are in a particular event and uh
and in particular event series unfolds while interacting with environment to
illustrate this further um chris gomez actually here is uh has done this work
and also provided this following illustration here when we um have now as the behavioral policy here for example
the gaze position of say an infant yeah and so um we might
start you might explain this equation a little bit further by the situation that okay the infant say it
he or she really likes uh teddy bears so basically it's really it's internal motivation is to look at teddy bear
teddy bears and um and it really perceives a lot of pressure out of that so it really likes to look at petty teddy bears and so its
observation is the desire to see teddy bear like objects
and thus by pursuing a policy that minimizes the
divergence from seeing petty teddy bears so it essentially will fixate teddy
bears but now when we now see uh that suddenly this
ball here is moving yeah um there might be a surprise in the observation because uh the baby probably
has expected that everything else will stay rather stably so um what's happening is that there is
a large uncertainty what this ball object is suddenly doing and where it's rolling from and this makes um the baby
for example look at the ball now because it wants to know how its rolls and build
a good predictive model so it's not surprised of the ball given it caught its attention in the
first place of course and so forth seems to be somewhat relevant for itself and so it actually predicts the next
ball locations and it will also continue then to most likely at least depending
on the age of course a little later age probably then illustrated in this picture here um predict that this ball
will eventually fall to the ground and thus it actually will at some point anticipate not only
the next ball position but we'll look at the critical next ball position which would be when does this object then
suddenly fall to the ground yeah and so we have a kind of a two event prediction the immediate next
situation and the uh event boundary when the ball switches from rolling into falling and
then expecting that it will fall somewhere on the floor and hopefully not on a teddy bear
so to get this really important and lo and behold um
the studies from from adam maurice uh it's adam and beget etzner um
is showing that uh in over the first year of
our human's life usually we develop this anticipatory event predictive eye gaze
behavior now so what they did is essentially they showed um little kids um little videos of hands grasping teddy
bears or little claw like grippers grabbers grasping teddy bears
or other simple kind of objects and what you can show is that when you track the
this baby's eyes for six months of age they don't show any anticipatory gaze behavior so they they track the object
the hand that moves to the target object at best usually they even lag a little bit behind but lo and
behold um with seven and a half months of age about um the
the babies start to anticipate and they do so
particularly and only so when there is an effect when the hand not only reaches
for that entity but then also lifts it so of course after so 12 trials are done there in this
experiment so usually in after the first or second try uh and the hand really shakes the object a little bit then um
the babies start to anticipate and they only do so with about 11 months when there is no effect when the hand just
reaches for the object but doesn't do anything with it so then they stay on reactive or hand following behavior and
only um do this later on only anticipate in a later age visit about 11 months old and interestingly
with a claw they at seven and a half they don't anticipate at all so they don't see any
agentiveness or any anticipation that this claw will do something with the object but with 11 months of age they
essentially show the similar behavior then when they watch a hand with seven and a half months in the hand lifts object the claw lifts the object then
they also start to anticipate with 11 months but only with 18 months they also anticipate
when the claw is not lifting the object but just moving there and lo and behold we simulated this with
our event predictive active inference model essentially um assuming uh so to
say simulating that until about six months of age they just don't cannot interpret the event of an
end reaching for objects and so they just cannot make an event
case out of it and they they just process the unexpected information that is the hand starts moving and they track
the hand um with 12 months of age it's similar still when they see a claw
but with 12 months of age when they see a hand and an object they imagine ah probably this hand wants to reach for
the object and so once the hand starts moving they will and they will move
their eyes to the object to be ready to process what the hand is going to do with the object
um and in fact we modeled this now um with an event
predictive patient modeling approach essentially that essentially implements this active
inference equation on the event predictive level that i just showed um so
it's it's certainly essentially first trained to learn a probabilistic event predictive
schemata of the unfolding dynamics starting in ending conditions and then it
applies active inference of the current best event interpretation first so it first
needs to know which event so if it sees the situation it needs to infer ah a reaching event is most likely to unfold
and once it's certain that the reaching and for event unfolds and it knows reaching ends with the grasping and
something doing something with the object so i will look there to minimize my future expected uncertainty
minimizing this anticipated uncertainty of what the hand is going to do with the object
and maybe you can look at the results in detail in the paper
essentially what is happening is that the system learns to during training to infer the
correct events and then during testing after sufficient training phases rather quickly it starts
to anticipate um uh when the reach starts here over time
um it starts to anticipate and look at the goal object because it has encoded
this is a reaching event and i know how the reaching event unfolds and thus i look at the end of the reaching event
because i want to minimize the the free energy that i anticipate
unfolding in the near future while reaching and grasping an object
because this is the situation that i'm currently in so that's what the system emergently so to say it does that's why
emerging golden inspiratory gaze by this active inference or event predictive active inference
formalism so okay we have shown that there are statin
static latent encodings that can nicely
foster the emergence of this inspiratory behavior but can such or how can such
event predictive structures actually learned this is what i want to show you next but you could also have a short
break if you like daniel or what you say
maybe ask and just double down on a few of these cool points and ask a few questions and then jump into the second part of the presentation
yep please okay um so a few just kind of general
questions one was you brought in the neural network angle and so it was just a general question
how do the analytical single line equation formalisms
connect to different modern machine learning architectures and what does that have to do with the scaling or
where active inference could be applied i think i can answer this in the second
part of my talk perfect okay this is going to become much more on your networks just now and i will
conclude also with a general statement about this so maybe we will keep this for later essentially um
i mean this was an lcm network lstm networks are used for uh state-of-the-art machine learning so
it's not like something um that is like totally trivial or so great and
uh the event basis is something that i'm sure you'll return to but
you mentioned how events have boundaries and schema or schemata and hierarchies and
one thought was how are these uh boundaries schema and hierarchies
learned in humans and how does that inform our design of cognitive systems
yes also this is kind of what i continue with essentially this is the question here okay so how
are these event predictive structures learned not so much in humans i will not so much
focus on in the talk now but how can this be lost in artificial systems but
inspired of course by human learning well i'm maximally uncertain and curious
about those i guess implicitly expected and prefer that they be resolved
but i hope so it just reminded me of how they're encultured like at the end of a movement of a symphony if you clap you
didn't get it because that's not the encultured moment to clap there's a broader event that actually goes beyond
the sound and so it just made me think about how through learning
we re-conceptualize what events are and if events truly are one of the
uh kind of atomic units of cognition then that's incredibly powerful
i would think so yes was this a question or a comment that was just a comment on the eve importance of having event-based
cognitive processes and um how it reconsiders our own experience and suggests how to design
other architectures so maybe we can go to the second part of the presentation the fantastic part is really right that it goes hand
in hand right while these events develop we are we getting more and more ready to look and explore deeper event structures
right and more complex event structures and of course the real mystery is how these event structures
are learned and i want to show you a couple of ideas that we are pursuing in our mainly
machine learning research part and in the last part of the talk i will link
these event structures also to language structures to a certain extent
so um but allow me the interest of time to go a little bit fast over this machine
learning components there because to i to explain the machine learning
architectures in all that detail it would take talks on on its own but i just want to give you a little bit of an
idea where we are in this respect but the main question that was asked and that's also really a
really good question is essentially what are these
how can our brain learn these event structures and there must be essentially
in machine learning jargon these inductive learning biases yeah these inductive
tendencies to learn these event predictive structures
and ideally to learn them in a very compact very suitably compressed
form to identify the causality
that generate the sensory perceptions in the first place and allow them to
combine these event structures in a very compositional very flexible manner such
that we get ready to um to apply our knowledge also in other situations that are related to previous
experiences but of course always different and
i've argued before that essentially they must on the one hand side be event
oriented interpretation tendencies in general as we have already seen in the quote from their baldwin for example
also so there must be we must essentially foster the development of this event predictive
stable and compact latent states this what seems what our brain seems to do
and it seems to develop these event states in terms of attempting to characterize
starting conditions contextual conditions and ending conditions of events so contextual conditions means
like when can an event unfold and what is happening typically why an event unfolds the starting condition means
when can this an event start yeah so i can reach only for an object when it's in reach so for example yeah and the
ending condition is essentially when an event ends so when a reaching event ends is typically when i grasp an object for
example and it appears that there is event predictive biases is inductive biases to
segment our stream of information into these events and two very important ones are
probably signals of surprise because usually when i don't have a good event or when i don't know exactly how an
event unfolds i get particularly first better to for example extend my hands reach for things
and so forth but then when i touch them i fail to grasp them properly and they fall down and this is surprising and
then i get surprise signals which over time
become non-surprising anymore because i know that when i reach for the object then typically the grasp unfolds and i
prepare for the grasp and then i manage the whole sequence without the surprises
and the other one is this latent signals of stability because and this also
relates to causality in a sense uh because our i mean our environment our
world is a three-dimensional space-time continuum essentially and forces or
causal interactions can only unfold when two entities can exchange these
forces and this is typically in the physical world only possible when they come in contact to each other now we are
in zoom and we we can exchange information over this long range um long range means but also in the
sense we are in contact right now right um by this tool by this digital device essentially
in the internet that um enables us to now um establish virtual rooms that's why a
zoom room for example is also called a zoom room yeah because it's a virtual room where we are together not
physically but information wise we can exchange information and and thoughts and ideas and so forth and that's
essentially very similar to being in the real room where typically similar things are mainly unfolding
and so this is the event predictive biases that make us structure our
environment and our thoughts and our general predictive models in this event
compositional manner and the other one is of course the importance of curiosity in homeostasis to make sure that we on
the one hand side essentially i mean our brain has does not have the capacity our
brain has a phenomenal capacity for sure but certainly doesn't have the capacity to learn everything in all its detail
about the world yeah i mean it's totally impossible i mean otherwise you would need to learn down to quantum mechanics
how everything unfolds the whole time right so this is um this is absolutely impractical
so of course we need to develop models that we believe so to say are best
suited for our needs right so while we build our models and why we pursue
active inference as you already seen in the active inference equation right there's this important component that
essentially tries to minimize the divergence between desired
perceptions and actual perceptions right and this is essentially maintaining internal homeostasis how fristen would
argue also that is this perception right that's not it's not necessarily only about the outside environment but it's
also the perception of your own body right so if you desperately hungry
or starving or whatever right then of course you do everything to prevent this from happening um
hopefully uh yeah it doesn't get to this um and
curiosity uh meanwhile of course drives our curious minds our knowledge gain
experience but also this knowledge gain experience is partially embodied so also our sensory system kind of signals to us
what is probably interesting for us and it's going hand in hand with the homeostasis component we build models
mainly about the stuff that really interests us and that we believe is important to us in our rich cultural
social world of course this can be very awkward very cool artistic things
and so forth but nonetheless right it is still in the human realm important
but when we do when we try to implement this now in artificial neural network structures
i want to show you a couple of brief glimpses at least at what we have done
in my group over the last couple of years the first that i want to show you is a derivative of this rocket ball
system where we now have again similar recurrent neural network structure but we have but we enhance the system now
not only processing sensory and motor information predicting sensory consequences as in the rocket ball thing
in that multi-joint arm that you saw before but also we allow it to give a contextual input
state which is essentially like an event state that develops
the ability to distinguish between different vehicles that the system is currently controlling notice or recall
that the system as a sensory input get gets xy positions of the vehicle
and motor commands are this two or four thrust motors
so it doesn't see which vehicle it's currently controlling it only sees its position
and so in order to distinguish the different vehicles it either needs to enhance its latent state within the long
shorter memory structure the car neural network structure or it needs to
contextualize a latent latent inductive bias essentially here and by training this it
lo and behold can do this now this is the trained model and it can has learned
to control these four three vehicles um that have different inertial and gravity properties and
um and also um thrust different thrust motors and just so does this now essentially by
on the one hand side continuously doing this active inference with a line that you see again the thought uh projecting
where it will be in the near future but also it retrospectively continuously
adapts its internal event estimate of which vehicle it's currently controlling or not really of which vehicle is
currently controlling but rather what's the best contextual state that allows me to predict the current sensing
motor dynamics in the best way and it does this uh rather well um lo and behold if you plot the internal
state this contextual state that emerges that's not trained or in a sense like
super traced not trained in a supervised way but it's trained via an active inference process essentially
um so it emerges like a distinction between the three different vehicles by
just simply optimizing this forward model of the dynamics of the different dynamics of
the three vehicles and having the inductive buyers that's important here to to succeed essentially that
the vehicles do not switch all the time but they are stable for a while like about 50 steps or something and then
they randomly switch at a certain point in time and and the inductive bias is that this
contextual vector that's hidden here essentially is a stable vector that only adapts itself
much slower than the internal dynamics of the actual recurrent neural network
and then during training such these structures typically emerge distinguishing the three
vehicles you can even train this to transport objects then there's some modularizations are possible unnecessary
to do so but admittedly these these structures do emerge but not
very robustly and the the structure of this latent state is still typically rather fuzzy so over the last two years
we essentially have produced a couple of other neural networks that really try to
work on this compression and the suitable compression of these latent states further
we have done this with various gating networks originally first still providing
surprise signals so essentially surprised when the switch occurs and we just give it a switch
a current signal that was last year essentially where we developed nice latent codes for
predicting some abstract functions for example and distinguishing between them even seeing some similarities between
them but then this year at
the coxah meeting we have done this again so we see we have this
event anticipation module this is a com still rather simple neural network then
we have event switching module that's a gated recurrent unit network here that
allows the next anticipation of the next event code or the passing of the next event code into the lower level event
processing structure that is actually processing the sensory information only at certain points in time when this
event boundary anticipation network actually activates the switch and this event boundary installation network
learns to activate the switch by a particular suitably designed inductive learning
biases so the first inductive part is essentially design of the model that you develop essentially an event processing
module that is contextualized by the belief of which what's the current most suitable event
code so what's the event that's unfolding and an event boundary anticipation module that essentially switches between events
just in time and lo and behold this system actually really does learn to switch when the information is there
that it can know when the event switches that it learns an optimal model about
the switches and if you have for example in this case we use like one hot encoded symbolic sequences and different
sequence processing automata basically then the system developed distinct event
codes for the three types of um dynamics for example and interestingly because you see uh
p1 the the event one or program one essentially um just switches between a and b p2
switches between b and c and three the problem three switches between a b c
b a b c b so it's a kind of a combination of problem one and problem two and so lo
and behold the p3 code essentially is between the p1 code and the p2 code in
all the cases although of course the different initializations there are three different networks they
of course develop different latent codes but they still um kind of uh and
imply the underlying structure of the events and the similarity between events
but uh maybe the most advanced network is the one here again from chris bergham
together joint work with martials here um this paper now that essentially also
has a very similar structure you have a hidden latent state as in the previous
previous code that's essentially in in this network it's it's this code that is passed down
through here and this hidden latent code is maintained over time and it's just
controlled or can be adjusted by a gate that's a multiplicative gate that opens only very selectively and this gate
is uh is designed such that there is a loss function
that punishes gate openings so the system really doesn't really want to open its
gate but if it's really helpful to lower the prediction error on the side
it does so it's also open the gate and thus changes context with this
this recommendation system or this event coding system that has the next event code
ready to switch to it just in time and then combines this to predict the next uh
consequences so again a sensory mode event predictive model essentially and um this system is now um quite ready
to um to process state-of-the-art challenges here
not only toy problems as in the admittedly in the last in two other systems so for example there's a
billiard ball scenario which is a kind of a benchmark the machine learning community where um our system
with suitable parametrization um decreases the mean squared error much
more than standard lstm or crew or standard recurrent neural networks and particularly when you have a testing
scenario that differs a little bit from the training scene and what's even more
important maybe or more interesting in this scenario is that matching to this illustration here you
see essentially that um the latent state of the our system called gate lord um
essentially you can really see that there is a particular dynamic unfolding right now
so first the ball rolls in a certain direction after the first interaction with the boundary
um the latent state perfectly switches to one stable new state and then you see
the second bounce and again it switches to a new state so um that's a very powerful a little
bit hand waving due to time cannot explain uh all of the all of the components here
but you see a really nice generalization behavior for example when you train only
this fetch and pick in place task in in situations where the gripper object contact always
occurs at time point five and in generalization the contact also
occurs at other time points um immediately the lstm and crew networks um
yeah get much worse in their predictive accuracy and gate lord still generalizes
also to these other scenarios and there are a couple of other um also combinations with reinforcement learning
systems so actually we took our the christian took that gate lord
module essentially this model learning module and combined it with state-of-the-art reinforcement learning
systems and as a result we could beat learn faster be more
sample efficient essentially and be it partially more accurate than the state-of-the-art reinforcement learners
in a couple of this mini grid world tasks for example so really important to
induce the right inductive learning biases these essentially improve um the latent state codes that
much more um systematically seem to develop um really ex kind of an
explaining called uh like explaining the causality in within with the latent code about
what's really going on in the environment such as where the sheep for example is
or where the goal position will be if if the system
remembers where the key is on one side and so forth so particularly very suited also for partially observable markov
decision process problems um so where you need to maintain longer term memory of particular events that
happened in particular environments okay
so that's the second part of the neural networks
and if you still have a couple of minutes i um try to
put you through the last component here that i wanted to show you that
event these event predictive structures can be very closely related to language
and that i find most exciting because this might in fact really close the
language gap and really around language in our sensory motor experiences by this
tendency to develop event predictive structures that are then very sim very easily
linked to the language that each of us experiences while we grow up let me show you what i
mean by this event predictive structures in terms of a language domain let's take this
this example of of a ball that rolled down the table because it was crooked for example yeah
and so if you read the sentence actually it was crooked yeah you you might think well the ball was crooked that's why i
drove down now it's probably was the table um so so how come we we are able
to make sense of this sentence with uh it particularly being ambiguous ambiguous being
referential ambiguity here being able to uh be bound to the subject or the object
essentially and so what i mean what happens when we read such a sentence is essentially that while we process
sending so we read the ball and we create probably a kind of a predictive encoding structure of the ball so the
ball can roll and bounce and it uh it gets repelled when it hits
something and it has some particular size and possibly we also imagine some kind of particular ball with
like a soccer ball or something depending on what i usually not very visual person so i don't
usually um imagine that an actual ball and then i then read rolled down so
the rolling is much more active than the falling at this point and i imagine the ball essentially rolling somewhere
somehow and then this somewhere somehow is specified it's the table so it rolls
uh down the table so apparently it's there's a table and there's a table top so it's probably on the surface of the
table that the rolling event unfolds and so i put this together and i have this rolling down as we've seen before the
baby expecting the rolling and the falling with now this event structure right of a ball rolling down meaning
like it rolled first on the surface and then it probably dropped down somewhere thus rolling down the table
and now uh we read because it was crooked essentially and this essentially
implies that because due to the because situation right um that essentially was the second part of the sentence was not
true like this is explaining part of the sentence it because part right so was it not crooked then the rolling event would
knock not take place and this essentially counter factual reasoning
right so um so can it be that the ball is crooked and thus it rolled down the table
and that's uh well if the ball would have some sort of crooked dent or whatever it's most likely has not rolled
down the table so that seems to be not so plausible so but a kind of a
tilted crooked table seems to be much more plausible so
most likely it was the table that was assigned with a pronoun right so we can
we have essentially analyzed the whole event with its causality in it by
imagining the words that we read and the sentence structure that we perceive as grammar and
generating an imagination of what we perceive and then actually we have um
this year with together with christian stigma and phillips we have published a paper on the so-called learner
architecture which essentially learns about an environment an event
predictive structure it is trained uh or informed how to um
link the individual event components that it has learned out
of its observing an environment with a language processes the system
and then it can in fact do just what i have illustrated it can disambiguate ambiguous sentences by
creating concrete imaginations of in a described state of affair so for example we have
here this this scenario yeah unfortunately it looks like little
viruses here this has nothing to do with corona or so sorry about it it was created before
the whole damn pandemic but nonetheless uh what's important is that these creatures here push down
stuff from this platforms and our learner system analyzes these things
and essentially creates even predictive structures out of it and so then after
it has learned this it can essentially generate sentence interpretations so after training essentially you can
create give it a sentence such as the green virus rests on the platform and it moves to the box after it faults so
rather complex sentence and what the system then is doing it can create itself out of the entities that are
uttered like a green virus a platform and a box which has been decided to be green here
as well that's randomly chosen then whether it's not specified it arranges these three objects in such
a way such that it it can imagine an event sequence unfolding in this constellation
to make this sentence true so you can see this in this video here so essentially the system
learned to generate this constellation that you see and the virus lo and behold
falls on the platform actually and then it rests on the platform for a little while
and then it moves to the box after it has fallen on the platform so this is
the interpretation of the sentence that the system has created and i think it's a nice illustration hopefully for you
also convincing illustration that this event structures or sentences uttering
event structures um can be the what we make of it what meaning making sense of
a sentence is essentially something like this is the the internal creation of a consistent event or event progression
that um fits to the described sentence structure disambiguating of course
certain temporal and uh and referential and so forth ambiguities that might be
inherent in the sentence and grammatical structure that is provided
we have also just recently shown that this event predictive inference structure also nicely
fits to the rational speech act model actually for that matter and one can nicely model
learning about the preferences of others
this essentially this example in this study goes with actual behavioral
experiments done on mturk here so for example you can imagine when you have a scene like this and this
is admittedly very abstract entities here and so for example you have the scenario
and maria wants to signal an object to the following scene in the following scene to samantha samaria maria says red
please take a red one essentially and samantha chooses the on light object like such as she takes the red cloud
here red stripe cloud then you can possibly infer something about samantha's preferences lo and behold she
might like for example clouds more than circles
but you don't know anything about squares because there was no option to choose from squares and
you can also by the active inference formalism within this formalism actually you can then
also do it the other way around and you want to for example possibly learn about
elizabeth's preferences and you have only the scenario can give options to choose amongst objects so for example if
you want to learn um about if the say if the person prefers
clouds or circles you could for example say pick one of the green ones and then
you would see if the person takes a cloud or circle and then you have some hint that
the person might um prefer clouds or circles for example and we have modeled this in this uh
recursive inference process very closely related to the active inference formalism usa typical kl divergence here
two kl kl divergence again where we um essentially compare
our prior knowledge of feature preferences over our expected
posterior knowledge of feature preferences while pursuing a particular action a particular utterance
and when we compare this to the actual behavior of the human participants we get really good fits and in fact could
show also from a from from information criterium um
manner that our cognitive model fits better than uh than other competitive models and this leads me to the end of
my presentation yeah so uh just the language really briefly in the end
but i hope you see what i mean by that this event predictive cognition essentially and the active inference
processes that unfold which is within these event predictive cognitive systems and our brains for that matter most
likely are very compatible to linguistic structures so what i have shown you today and i
hope you uh could follow me so far it wasn't too much um that essentially our
generative mind yeah may health may have the self-motivated objective to act
highly flexibly and goal-directed and pursue epistemic self-motivated actions in general this is quite clear to
survive right to interact with our complex worlds to seeing that we have become this crazy human beings with all
our social likes and hates and capabilities and intelligence and so forth
on this human cognitive level event predictive conceptualizations seem to be
really important to enable us to act in a deeper goal-directed self-motivated
manner and to conceptualize our environment as to be able to communicate
and interact and cooperate with others and compete also with each other for that matter in a highly more
sophisticated manner than any other animals can to learn such conceptualizations we
really need this inductive learning biases and certainly not fully figured out yet how this learning and processing
biases are working working or functioning but we know one can show clearly that
these contributions are really good to enable deeper goal-directed self-motivated planning
reasoning counterfactual reasoning filling in gaps finishing unknowns
disambiguating ambiguous situations and pursuing
abstract and concrete behaviors on multiple levels and last point was that language seemed to
be mapped really rather simplistic rather easily on this uh which essentially possibly
might explain why we as babies naturally learn our
mother tongue without much overly much effort and particularly the
complexity of the grammar behind it also now on the artificial intelligence side i would like to conclude that
that the current deep learning systems mostly because they don't foster this generativity and this conceptualization
of structures um they do not really foster event predictive genitive models and as others
have said thus men may call on the more simpler architectures that are
nonetheless including systems like transformers and so forth really still
rather highly computationally mining stochastic parrots
arguably and interesting to discuss this of course i believe that if we develop more event
predictive generative systems then we actually foster the development of
the learning of generative models that is and ideally causal models of the actual
true causality that we encounter via our sensory motor experiences enabling us to
generate much more robust for cars possible action recommendations and explanations also why we would recommend
particular things of forecast particular things because we essentially are designed to learn about the causes
that lead us to predict certain things so we can also of course talk about the causes
and in my opinion these systems may then indeed yield strong ai or artificial general intelligence um
where self-motivated learning will be inevitable part of such systems
and self-motivated learning and self-modded behavior also thus will be part of the systems
and so i think it's we should be aware that there is no reason
i see no recent research on human cognition and its functionality is no reason why
an artificial system should not reach such uh intelligence level
and so as others also have pointed out i want to conclude with a
with a word of caution essentially and a word of awareness that
if these systems come into being come into existence yes we need to make very much sure that
we don't design them just for profit or for some
individual personal interest but we better put good purpose
into these systems and it's a good idea to think about this now also
this concludes my talk thank you so much for attention parts of this general motivation background you can find in my
book from 2016-17 how the mind comes into being and i
acknowledge some funding from humboldt foundation and dfg mainly and thank you for my team
actually to produce much of this work i don't have a team slide here and but uh thank you for your attention as well
awesome presentation thank you very much thank you maybe you can unshare and we can
have a little discussion
well tons of very interesting ideas anyone can write a question in the chat but let
me just start with a introductory question how did you come to be working with
active inference models what were you working on before was it a system
specific or question specific path that led you to integrate these novel
components into active inference
yes thanks i just little bit confused because it's this camera now yeah okay
um well let me let me actually turn to this screen then
yes well i have studied all my research career
essentially started to study anticipatory behavior from the very early on during my
diploma bachelor's degree studies essentially coming into contact with a psychologist in whittsburg jorge
hofmann's group and inspiratory behavior control and i think in his work he already
essentially from the psychological perspective of formalizes
this principle of active inference on a very crude more inwards specified
psychological level where and i started very early then to also realize that
that well the devil is in the details
um the the big question is really what are representations like yeah what what
is the representations that these anticipations that these predictions actually unfold what what's the nature
of these representations and even now nowadays we still see lots of machine learning work where
representations are given in advance and so forth and
or are just totally done by let's say the atari games or these successes i mean there
you just give the plain image and you you kill the problem with so much data
that it still converges but the system is not really learning the systematicity the actual
structure of the problem and but most recent advances of course also from others for example the
the dreamer architecture or the planet architecture from from
what's his name hafner is the last name this score is also very close in this direction but no
no half now yeah yes they goes in this direction but they
don't really foster event predictive latent codes yet and i think they should
cool um i have some
predictions about where you might go but just to sort of restate it you said just in your previous answer that it was a
crude active inference in words and so i wanted to ask what is active
inference crudely in words and then what key
uh pieces of the formalism today refined those words and then what do you see
being incorporated into the formalism going forwards
so what's what's active inference crudely speaking and what
well it's uh active inference essentially formalizes
how our minds and how clever learning systems
should infer develop generative models about the world
and use these models to pursue self-motivated co-directed behavior
that's the general formalism and my point today was essentially that this
formalism is overly general in a sense because it doesn't specify
the nature of the encodings of the predictive codings and evolution has
obviously shaped our minds such that we have
particular expectations of this suitable of the structure that's suitable to
model the outside environment and thus interact with this environment in a more flexible adaptive
goal-directed socially competent manner and that's where the event predictive
stuff falls in thank you for the answer now a sequence of events
might have a narrative could be said that connects them how does narrative relate to your
work here is that just a bigger nesting event or how do we connect micro scale
events which it's very nice how you know rolling off the table was a clear demonstration of that kind of an event
how does that connect to broader narratives yeah very good uh question very good and
very interesting um is i think
as i said in uh as i try to imply also um that the events exist on multiple levels
of granularity and precision and an event can consist of yet sub-events essentially right i mean like
the whole episode of writing a letter for example consists of writing individual words sentences paragraphs
thoughts uh expressing individual thought components and so forth right so
so and so an event per se um can i mean you have the event of your
current day right and you compress this awesome event so so there's so that's the beauty
about it i think also because um an event it's not
it's not there's not only one event unfolding in our minds in every here and
now situation but it's it's about this
different aspects that have beginnings and endings right like this like this meeting here but my answer to your
question my individual sentences my individual words my actual utterances that i produce
these are all events nested within each other and each of these components is
characterized by certain stability situations like the whole
while we have this meeting um we are in a certain interactive situation and this is more or less
stable during the whole meeting yeah i guess i'm the presenter here today and so forth and then we have listeners and
you are the the mediator so to say right and this is the situation the whole time and this is
stable from from the beginning of the end from the whole situation right but when you post me a question then you focus in on this question answering
situation event and that's one particular event which is nested within the other event and while i produce my
train of thought there are also the events again unfold right so there's so there's a lot and and each of these car
events though is characterized by certain stabilities that are unfolding
such as the question answer situation where we focus on a particular component of this current talk and the current
topic of this meeting awesome what that reminded me of was
kronos and kairos two greek word roots for time and the chronometer that the
decimal points and the time and there's nesting of chronology like the second is
within the deca second or the you know the minute the hour but then kairos this
more semantic or action-oriented kind of timeliness also has nesting and that can be
perfectly nesting like the example of the letter with the sentence the word
etc it's funny because it's called a letter right at the bigger and the smaller level
but then also the boundaries could be uh subjective so not to say arbitrary
but literally defined by the subject learnt by the subject and so it seems to be no problem to have machine learning
systems that can nest kronos very well but how do we achieve um inadequate
nested action-oriented representation um
any thoughts or ask a question from the chat i think um the
that's the very important part and that's also the beauty i think about the event structures right that essentially
it's not it's always subjective because it's the stability that each of us perceives that makes an event become
an event now and i mean because our world for us is all the same we are very similar in
these event structures but nonetheless of course the events are very individually
unfolding in each of our minds and they are characterized by these stability and
systematicity properties that each event has and the nice thing about it as well is
that the petitioning and segmentation is extremely flexible right i mean you can
it doesn't depend on time in order to thus implement this in machine learning
systems you need to have a system that can flexibly maintain particular latent states over
extended periods of time and systematically change them when the time is ripe so to say and this is what we
have done with the gate lord system that i have showed towards the end which is going to be
published in december very cool so i'll ask a question from
the chat so dean has asked entertaining counterfactuals is time
distributing and time provides the twist like a mobius strip so if we include diachronic continuity
with event episodic partitioned do we break free from training
a classical a classical dean phrasing to be sure which i just read literally
rather than choose to interpret but maybe you can help me with the
interpretation but uh i would say um the the counterfectional component
was the problem that the counterfactual is time demanding or consuming or mentally challenging essentially to
because time is on the issue and so i need to be so i cannot do counterfactual reasonings
on the fly and uh that's certainly true we have um we fall typically in our best
explanation very quickly and habitually and only when we
really realize errors we fall into counterfactuals i usually give
the example with a cricket ball actually usually i give a simple example which is non-dynamic like the ball fits
into suitcase because it is large for example
so the ball fits into the suitcase because it is large yeah so it is
suitcase that is large and not the ball and um and that is kind of also a
typical garden pass effect in in linguistics here you fall into the best interpretation the pronoun it usually
fits with the subject and so uh you your best hypothesis to to bind it to the subject and you read on and then you get
to the final sentence and then you try to imagine why does the ball fit in the suitcase and then essentially you
realize you have to revise your model yeah and that's kind of the counter factual part that only happens i think
when there is surprise or other reasons to really pursue this additional cognitive effort
great answer let me see if there's a link to what dean suggested and the stochastic parrot
notion so if we think about a stochastic seed
preferring seed rewarding parrot it's like there's some maze and the seed
could be on either side and so it's rewarded when it's discovering that it's strengthening that and then it switches
and then it just stochastically sometimes investigates the other branch and then reinforces that
now that's all time bound if we think about the
event as the context then the counterfactual the continued
possibility of imagining a counterfactual is kind of what allows
the rapid moving from the training on the side that it has been on
and in one step with one gate opening we can counter factually
enter into a different context and then he adds um it's bidirectional
and the not present is that now let me restart this literally he says the not present is now
plus then and then plus now this is our ability both episodic and
diachronic continuity that is the what if the mind can work out
yes and that's that's a that's a beautiful part right i mean our mind can essentially by these gate openings
create a switch between alternative
events or event sub-event components switch the entity property
uh switch other aspects of it and and uh and it not needs to do so it's
not only doing this by randomly switching these things because it usually switches them very systematically in a meaningful manner
that actually the consequence of an event actually um changes it well right
because you usually do what if questions that actually change the further event progression
and you can do this mentally really well and i think the this essentially
can could be done and should be further explored with such gating mechanisms
really cool um component for future research i think to really show that such systems not only are able to
explain events but can also really reason in terms of counterfactual manners then by
saying well if i switch if this property would have been different then actually the whole thing
would have not happened this is actually also really important to assign blame for example
two people um would would you not have uh shot the ball yeah or something like this and and
so that's um that's also very socially relevant um lo and behold there
as well as designing education and thinking about when are we trying to
when are we fine tuning but not chain opening or changing a gate and then it made me think about that
the equation which you did an awesome job to walk through and show and read it because like sensory motor inputs
the the equation is a linear string but then we can engage in this counterfactual
what if the inference on observables weren't conditioned on policy
and it's actually to have competency with those equations is to
know a little bit about counterfactuals and then on the cutting edge you're drawing from other fields and
you're asking looking at pizzullo and fristen at all 2015 and then asking well what if this
formalism included another event-based cognitive framework that was
not previously connected so it's like the learning trajectory for those of us
who are learning the equations includes the counterfactuals and the gate opening and then research is just kind of going
one step further and um so just maybe wonder about how we
design education to accommodate this kind of gate opening and counter factual
space how we accommodate education um
like what what for what kind of education you mean yes
what which education you're referring to human
human education for learning active inference or for learning another area
yeah i think that's like a good interesting far thought i would say
it's it's i think it's extremely useful for sure to
yeah particularly also to look at equations and and analyze their components
and then progressively also enhance them or selectively compact them take
kick away out the one summoned or the other and then you see exactly what's happening so
i guess hopefully this was educational how i presented it i guess
it's a flow of sensory inputs and then there's some different structures
if you think about the individual components in the equation as as event
components in the sense very cool um i have one more
question and then maybe any closing thoughts you mentioned you know the the zoom room or the the jitsi room online
events calendar events that we all get invited to um
that's just very interesting with how we're bringing our evolutionary and our ecological
behavioral embodiments into the digital space and so
what does it bode for online events thinking beyond just uh webinars but
like how do we think about online events because in one sense you're very local to me you're in my headphones giving me
the sensory flow but you're on a different continent and so where do you think
or what theoretical questions or applied questions does it raise to think about online events which are a novel affordance from an evolutionary
perspective
i mean i think for the one for the one good of it they have shown us that we don't need to
fly as much around the globe as we have done before the pandemic which is probably a really good thing
for our planet and we should acknowledge this and accept this i think
i have the impression that particular older colleagues have issues with that
and i think it's it's very good an important thing that we should be all
aware of that um and shrouded out loud as i do right now that
we are in a in a very severe situation for our world and um this pandemic has shown us also
and even shows us now how the humans are so easily able to
neglect things or deny things that are so obvious that they are occurring which is very scary and very
unfortunate for our own future meanwhile saying this
i think it's it was a great opportunity to
for all of us to acknowledge that video calls like this work really well
and of course um after one and a half years of pandemic i guess all of you guys also enjoy um
local meetings again and and going out with other people so we also see how
social creatures are and what is missing in such video calls which is of course the
personal interaction and the really the development of of getting a feel of
how the other person really takes also personally and when you can make a statement about what's actually
happening in true life out there that's of course um very different unfortunately not possible
we are zoom calls um but so i can only urge everybody that uh um
we should be aware that when we fly around the world we better make it worth the while and don't do this only for a
couple of days it made me think of a trilemma
uh fly we could have met in person you know we could have met in iceland or something somewhere in the middle
um there is an impact in the hardware and the bandwidth of a video call and that
impact is very cloaked and then there's also machine learning
models and so maybe somehow i don't know if x is the impact of a flight
is a video call point one or one thousandth or one millionth of a flight and making some of these
impacts that are very real clearer so that we can
design events that are policies that align with our preferences
to reduce our uncertainty and to connect socially but also to
pragmatically keep certain ecological parameters within a region that we can
thrive in yes absolutely that would be good i mean a video call is certainly even less than
the millions i think from a flight although of course it is significant but
it's i mean incomparably less and
but nonetheless one has to be of course also be aware that um yeah unfortunately we are in a
situation where we really need global efforts so one cannot really point fingers to individual persons because we
need global policy changes to save our own world and our future of our children and
i have three kids and i'm very concerned
do you have anything that you'd like to just leave us with or that's a perfect closing note
no i don't want to leave on the downside sure it was a great pleasure to to do
this uh with you guys and now we drifted a little bit to the climate situation and i'm i'm thankful that we also can talk about
this a little bit and uh but i hope it's it i mean it's hopefully you also see
that it's an amazingly exciting topic and uh not only one inside how our human
mind works and how we manage to be as intelligent
but also as limited as we are in the end and but meanwhile also i think it has
certainly ai is is amazingly developing over the last
couple of years and um yes and and there i guess also uh things
go so fast so it's important that we uh think about
the dangers of a iron unfortunately as we have seen with cambridge analytica as
only an example of what is going on right now in terms of ai driven
targeted influence of our own selves and our way we think
about stuff and our beliefs and hopefully we will manage also to foster this awareness of this and thus
be more ready to counteract it and find back to our beautiful human social abilities
thank you for that excellent and uplifting note it was really an honor martin so thanks
again for the presentation and the chat really appreciated as well you and any colleagues are always
welcome to come on a live stream or to get involved in an act in flab in any way so this was
just a great conversation and it was hopefully very informative for our audience as well
i hope so too um thanks for inviting me here and thanks for running this lab it seems to be a really good group and i
hope you can stay in contact over the next months and years thank you we will